this is potentially quite significant
mark
as you say edwin poot the agriculture
minister who last year was briefly the
dup leader has ordered the top civil
servant in his department over in
stormont in northern ireland to stop
carrying out the checks that are
necessary as part of the northern
ireland part of the deal uh brexit deal
that boris johnson did with brussels at
the end of 2020. now this is likely to
put huge pressure on brussels to respond
and also on westminster as well but
tonight the main uh the the main
consequent is one of uncertainty edwin
poots has given this instruction to his
top official but it's not yet clear
whether the official will carry it out
there appears to be a dispute about the
legal advice provided to edwin poots
others say it's illegal for that
official to effectively stop the checks
and in doing so break the law themselves
so there will be conflicting advice
about whether the official can follow
the instruction of the minister of
course northern ireland works on the
basis of an executive that is uh that
jointly shares power uh and tonight shin
fein have come out and said that they
regard the instruction by edwin poots as
illegal and wrong and therefore you
don't even have a united position in the
northern ireland government about how to
proceed uh the issue must also be uh be
considered by westminster do westminster
ministers does liz trust effectively
overseeing the northern ireland protocol
now
and those negotiations that are still
unresolved and ongoing does liz trust
countermount end with boots uh and tell
officials in northern ireland uh that
they do have to carry out the checks in
order to try and keep those negotiations
with brussels alive or do we end up in a
situation where brussels feels forced to
retaliate it is at the beginning of a
quite a long process where lots of the
actors have yet to set out uh what they
believe needs to happen next but it is a
massive headache not only for civil
servants in northern ireland but for
boris johnson's government which
essentially will now have to decide
whether to back the dup or smack them
down and countermand them